[موسيقى]
المؤرخ الفرنسي الان روسو الذي انتقد
بلاده على تكريمها ذكرى جزار الشعب
الجزائري جنرال الاحتلال والارهاب مارسيل
بجار يقول ان العداء الممنهج للاسلام
متجذر تاريخيا في الفكر الغربي ومنبعه
الغزوات الصليبيه وان هذا العداء يتابع
الان روسو قد ازدهر اثناء التوسع
الاستعماري الاوروبي واستعاده قوته حديثا
مع الحرب على الارهاب الى العناوين
فرنسا تعتبر الارهاب الاسلامي السني ابرز
تهديد لاوروبا
ماكرون يجرم الاساءه الى شخصه
بالكاريكاتير ويبيح اهانه الانبياء
شيخ شيعي يحرم انتخاب كليتش
ويعتبره خطرا على الاسلام
السلطه الفلسطينيه اسرائيل تشن حربا دينيه
ضد الاسلام في القدس
ايران تطالب افغانستان بعوده المياه الى
مجاريها ومبين خان يسخر
عيدروس الزبيدي يقترح ثلاثه اسماء لدولته
الانفصاليه بجنوب اليمن
اللبنانيون تناسوا جحيم اوضاعهم وانقسموا
حول الاحتشام على الشاطئ
نجمه الافلام الاباحيه المعتزله ميا خليفه
مكرمه في جامعه اوكسفورد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من عقدته الطائفيه ضد المسلمين الى
ورم المذهبيه الخبيث ضد المسلمين السنه
بالتحديد يعبر وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
الصغير جيرال دارماننا فيعتبر من امريكا
ما وصفه بالارهاب الاسلامي السني ابرز
تهديد لفرنسا واوروبا بغض النظر عن من
يشمل تصنيفه فتصريحاته السابقه تظهره انه
لا يستثني احدا حتى ان اجهزته الامنيه
طلبت مؤخرا من المدارس الابتدائيه كشفا
باسماء الاطفال المسلمين الذين تغيبوا يوم
عيد الفطر وايا كان الدوافعه هو يعلم ان
المسلمين عندما كانوا حقا يشكلون تهديدا
لمن يهددهم ما كان هلكه من هنا ولكيع من
هناك يجرؤ ان يقول ما قاله سليل جد جزائري
عميل تجند مع محتل بلاده وقتل مواطضيه على
مذبح الخيانه بحسب تعليق باحثين عرب في
الانثروبولوجيا والسيكولوجيا
والسوسيولوجيا والتاريخ على تصريحات اصغر
وزراء باريس في حكومه اصغر رئيس فرنسي
شباب جاء ذلك على هامش زياره يقوم بها
الوزير الفرنسي الى الولايات المتحده
لتعزيز التعاون الامني مع واشنطن واكد
دارمان انه يريد التذكير انه بالنسبه الى
الاوروبيين ولفرنسا الخطر الاول هو
الارهاب الاسلامي السني ما يغتصب نساء
بلاده لا يتبرعوا عن اغتصاب سمعه الاخرين
وثقافتهم وامنهم درمنا متهم بالاغتصاب على
نطاق الاوروبيا واسع وجهت اليه اتهامات
بالاعتداء الجنسي والتحرش عام 2018 لكنه
نفاها واغلقت القضيه لنقص الادله والدته
عامله نظافه وبقيت كذلك حتى بعد تعيين
ابنها وزيرا طبعا تنظيف المنازل عمل مشرف
ولا عيب فيه لكن العيب في ثقافتنا التي
تهدد مخيله جيرالدين الصغير هو ان يترك
الانسان والديه يعملان لتحصيل رغيف اليوم
وكفافه وهو حي يرزق ويسعى فكيف اذا كان
عمل والديه متعبا وغير لائق بكبار السن
المدهش في الامر ان
والده الحوارات عن سبب استمرار امه كامله
نظافه رغم كونهم وزيرا للداخليه فاجاب
سؤالك غير لائق نعم لا زالت امي عامله
النظافه سبط جده الخائن لبلاده الجزائر ذو
الاصول المختلطه بين الاسلام واليهوديه
والنازح الى المسيحيه كما يحاول ان يوحي
للاخرين يوصف بانه عصى مكرون مسلط على
المسلمين الفرنسيين وهو وماكرون تسبب
باكبر حمله مقاطعه شعبيه اسلاميه لمنتجات
فرنسا ما تزال مستمره منذ اكثر من سنتين
38 عاما المنحدر من اصول مالطيه يهوديه
لابيه وجزائريه مسلمه لامه فحفيد المسلم
الذي قاتل ضمن جيش فرنسا ضد بلده الجزائر
اليوم الوجه الاكثر تشددا في حكومه
ايمانيول الماكرون والواجهه العامه
للاجراءات الفرنسيه المشدده حيال ما تسميه
باريس المجتمعات والمؤسسات الاسلاميه
الانفصاليه داخل المجتمع الفرنسي وما يزال
البحث جاريا عن اسباب فوبيا بعض المنظومه
الفرنسيه من الاسلام مع ان الطبيعي هو ان
تكون لدى المسلمين والافارقه فوبيا من
العنف الدموي الفرنسي التاريخي الذي لا
يقل وحشيه عن دمويه ادولف هتلر وجوزيف
ستالين واندريت شيكاتيلو حتى ان هؤلاء لم
يحتفظوا عند حد علمنا بجماجم ضحاياهم
وعرضها في المتاحف كما فعل الفرنسيون
بالجزائريين المسلمين حتى في مسجد كتشاوه
التاريخي بالجزائر لم يتعفف الغزاه
الفرنسيون عن ارتكاب مجزره قتلوا فيها
اكثر من اربعه الاف مصل اعتصموا في المسجد
قبل تحويله الى كنيسه ولم تعتذر فرنسا حتى
الان فرنسا تاريخ اجرامي في افريقيا
وسيطره مستمره مجازر بلا هواده واباده
جماعيه للشعوب مجاعات وفقر ونهب للثروات
وترسيم عشوائي للحدود بين الدول الافريقيه
عم نحكي كتير عنهم مهن مشتركين وقت لغيرهم
وهن مسؤولين بدوله كبيره مش مجرد متطرفين
عاديين
اخر ما توصل اليه ايريك زمور لهلوبه
الطائفيه الفرنسيه والمرشح الرئاسي السابق
هو ادعائه ان الجزائر ارض مسيحيه غزاها
الاسلام المفارقه ان ايريك بكلامه عم
يتنكر لاصله الجزائري وهو يهودي بالمناسبه
للجيرين
ملصقات تنتشر في باريس تشبه الرئيس
ايمانويل
باهانه الرئيس لكل من شارك في جريمه رسم
الشوارب هتلر فوق تمه لمكروم بماذا يذكركم
هذا الخبر وبسرعه الضوء الهيئه العالميه
لنصره نبي الاسلام ذكرها الخبر باعتبار
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه الرسوم المسيئه التي
وصفت النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالارهابي اعتبرتها جزءا من حريه التعبير
وفي نفس الوقت ترفض اليوم هتلره ماكرون
واعتباره زعيما ارهابيا برسم كاريكاتوري
فاين حريه التعبير يا فرنسا تسال الهيئه
هذه الرقاب سنرى كيف تذل وتقهر
الا تنحنون لنبيكم
نحن لا نركع لغير الله وحده
محمد علمنا انه عبد الله ورسوله الحق الحق
اقول لكم ان الذي جاء به محمد والذي جاء
به المسيح
يصدر من سراج واحد
[موسيقى]
على بعد نحو اسبوع من الجوله الثانيه
والحاسمه الانتخابات تركيا التي ستنتج
فائزا بالرئاسه ومعتزلا للسياسه يجتهد
المرشحان رجب طيب اردوغان وكمال كليتش في
المحافظه على غله الدوره الاولى اولا ثم
اضافه كل ما يمكن من الاصوات لتعزيز الرقم
وتثبيت النجاح ثانيا لكن الخمسه بالمئه
التي ضاعت منهما في الدوره الاولى لصالح
المرشح الثالث يبدو انها ستتوزع عليهما
مناصفه فقد اعلن المرشح الخاسر سنان اوغان
دعمه اردوغان لكن شريكه المنفصله عنه
عن دعمه كليتش دارولو ملمحا بتغريده الى
انه وعد بان يكون وزير الداخليه الذي
السوريين من تركيا كمال كليتش ده روغلو
وحملته يتعلقون الان بحبل اللاجئين
السوريين فرفعوا عددهم بخطاباتهم من ثلاثه
الى عشره ملايين واعيدين بترحيلهم في
اليوم التالي للفوز ما استدعى كشفا
بالارقام قدمه وزير الداخليه سليمان سويلو
وردا من اردوغان وامي
ره
يدعو الناخبين الى التصويت له احتراما
للمراه التركيه لان منافسيه ينظرون الى
الفتيات نظره سوء يقول
ماذا يقصد بان خصومه ينظرون نظره سوء
للمراه
هل هو نفس الاتهام من اللاتينيه الغربيه
المتشدده ويندرج اعاده حجاب المراه وحريه
العباده في تركيا ضمن توجد محجبات معه
معلاناته حتى ان العلمانيه المتشدد كليتش
وزعت اوساطه فيديو قديما عندما كان ضيف
احتفال عاشورائي حاشد بالمحجبات وبالشادور
واستقبله الحشد
بهتافات لبيك يا حسين
لبيك يا حسين
[تصفيق]
داعيا الى عدم الاغترار بما وصف بخطابه
المذهبي الشيخ الشيعي السيد باسم الشرع
يحرم التعاطف مع كليتش ده روغلو لانه
برايه يشكل خطرا على الاسلام في تركيا
السيد الشرع هو امام مركز الزهراء في
ميشيغن بامريكا
بحاول يتقرب للناخبين
بحبه باظهاره حب علي بن ابي طالب عليه
السلام لا من عقيده وانما تسويق انتخابي
والا الحزب الجمهوري حزب اتاتورك ومعروف
اتاتورك ماذا فعل بالاسلام
وكيف تعامل مع المقدسات الاسلاميه هو الذي
وقف في البرلمان التركي كمال اتاتورك وقال
لا نريد كتابا يمنينا بالتين والزيتون
يقصد الايه والتين والزيتون يستهزئ
بالقران هذا اذا اجوا للرئاسه الله اعلم
ماذا يفعلون يلغون الحجاب يفعلون ما
يشاءون ولذلك لا ينبغي انه الانسان يتعاطف
معهم ولو ذكروا عليان انها حرب دينيه
تشنها دوله الاحتلال ضد كل ما هو اسلامي
في مدينه القدس المحتله يقول مستشار
الرئيس الفلسطيني للشؤون الدينيه محمود
الهباش وذلك تعليقا على اقتحام مستوطنين
بزعامه وزير الامن القومي الدموي
بن كبير المسجد الاقصى في موازاه جمع
بنيامين ياهو حكومته المتطرفه في نفق تحت
الاقصى ليصح فيها وصف حكومه تحت الارض
عشره المتطرفين الصهاينه يتقدمهم كبيرهم
المسمى وزير الامن القومي اتمرنغفير
يقتحمون المسجد المبارك ويؤدون في ساحاته
طقوسا تلموديه ويستمعون لشروحات عن هيكل
مزعوم رغم كيد نتنياهو وحكومته المتطرفه
لكن الفلسطينيين والعرب اطمئنوا عندما
سمعوا الرئيس محمود عباس في قمه جده يشكر
جهود الزعماء العرب تجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه
تحيه كبار وتقدير
لاشقائنا قاده الدول العربيه
وشعوبها على مواقبهم الثابته تجاه شعبنا
وقضيتنا العادله كما
ونرحب بزياده الرئيس بشار الاسد رئيس
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه اخا عزيزا بين
اهله واخوانه
[موسيقى]
في المتفرقات حضر الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيس حكومه افغانستان من مغبه خفض حصه
بلاده في مياه نهر هلمند الحدودي الذي
يشهد جفافا نسبيا بحسب رد حكومه كابول هذا
التوتر بين البلدين استدعى افاد طهران
وفدا امنيا رفيعا الى كابول لمحاوله اعاده
مياه نهر هلمندا الحدودي الى مجاريها فهل
سيعود الوفد بما يريد ام بجره مبين يسال
معلقون اما مبين فهو القيادي في طالبان
مبين خان ملا جره مياه من نهر هلمند وخاطب
الرئيس الايراني واعدا اياه بانه سيرسلها
اليه بعد تهديداته التي اخافتنا يقول مبين
ساخرا
واخطار ناتمه
باخبار مسلمين الهند شريطه فيديو قالت ان
ارهابيا هندوسيا من عصابات الهندفا يظهر
فيه وهو يحاول بكل قوته ان يقتل مسلمه
محجبه بركله منه عندما كانت تسير في
الشارع وقد سقطت فورا على الارض رئيس
المجلس الانتقالي اليمني الجنوبي عيدروس
الزبيدي يخشى من انشقاق حضرموت عن الدوله
الجنوبيه الانفصاليه التي يسعى بدوره الى
فصلها عن اليمن
ويغري الحضارم بان اسم حضرموت هو ثالث
ثلاثه اسماء مقترحه للدوله الموعوده لانه
في كثير رهن ان دوله حضرموت يعني
خارجه على سرب الجنوب بالرغم
دائما ومن الخيارات المجلس انت غالي
الجنوبيه
ثلاثه خيارات للدول القادمه
جنوب عربي او دوله حضرموت او جمهوريه
بينما كان حزب الله ينفذ مناوره عسكريه
امام الكاميرات اهتم بها الاعلام
الاسرائيلي والعالمي ونفذ فيها محاكاه
لاقتحام مستوطنات اسرائيليه وبينما كانت
مذكرات الاعتقال الاوروبيه تتوالى بالصدور
بحق حاكم مصر في لبنان وبينما تستقر
الليره اللبنانيه في قعرها التاريخي بعد
سرقه ودائع اللبنانيين المصرفيه وتهريبها
مع تسجيل ارتفاع حالات انتحار الشباب
والمراهقين وبينما يخشى معظم اللبنانيين
من عدم توفر لقمه ودواء وكتاب الغد انشغل
البلد طولا وعرضا بحريه البيكيني على شاطئ
صيدا ردا على ما قيل انه منع شيخ لامراه
ارادت ارتياد الشاطئ بلباس البحر طبعا
ليست وظيفه الشيخ ان يكون حارس البلديه
التي تلزم الزوار باللباس المحتشم وبعدم
ادخال الخمور الى الشاطئ العام هذه
الشعارات فعليا هي لمواجهه تظاهر مدنيه
تعترض على الاعتداء الذي تعرضت له ميساء
منذ ايام للباسها البكيني واعتراضا ايضا
على قرار البلديه التقيد بلباس المحتشم
على الشاطئ لما اشخاص بيعتمدوا على الحريه
العامه هاي اخر هاي مساحتنا دوله من حقنا
انها تحمينا الشاطئ للكل على منطقه من
المناطق الخاطئه لحزب الله بتقدر وحده
تنزل على النهر بالشورت حدا يقول لي
بغض النظر نحنا هيك بلبنان ماسمي مناطيا
ونحن رضيانين قبل نحو خمس سنوات طردت
عائله من شاطئ في شمال لبنان لوجود نساء
محجبات بينها الطرد رافقه سير من الشتائم
واوضح عضو مجلس بلديا في ح ينه للاعلام
المحلي ان اي لباس غير المايوه بما فيه
لباس راهبات ممنوع افضع من ذلك ما قصه منع
المحجبات والسوريين والكلاب من ارتياد
شاطئ لعيبه عنوانه تقرير بثته قناهه
الجديد اللبنانيه قبل اربع سنوات
والمحجبين والسوريه
او فهمتوا الموضوع يا عيب الشوم عليكم هي
ثلاثيه صدمت الراي العام بعدما نشر الفنان
اللبناني المرقده فيديو ينتقد فيه اداء
بلديه لعيبه بمنعه من ادخال كلبه الى شاطئ
للعموم كاميرا الجديد توجهت الى الشاطئ
للاطلاع عن كثب على هذه التدابير المزعومه
حيث استقبلتنا هذه اللافته التي تعز
بارتداء لباس البحر فقط كل هذه الحوادث
المتنقله في الشواطئ التي تمنع نزول
المحجبات اليها لم تلقى اعتصاما نسويا
واحدا لذلك وقبل ان يبدل اللبنانيون
نظامهم من الطوائفيه التوافق الى اي شيء
اخر لعل الحكمه تكون في مقاله الصحفي طوني
ابي نجم لماذا لا تكون هناك مناطق
للمايوهات واخرى لغيرها كما يحصل بين دبي
والشارقه في الامارات مثلا
فالاخر ايضا لا يتقبل اللباس الشرعي على
شواطئه البلديه بصيدا بكل واقعيه منتخبه
الجو بصيدا
باكثر فيها وبالتالي انه اللي يحب بينزل
بالمايوه عمليا قادره يروح خمس دقايق او
ثلاثه
اذا سيده او صبيه اجت مره تنزل بجونيه او
بجبيل بكل ثيابه على البحر او ببركنيه
الشرعي الناس كله راح يطلعوا فيها بشكل
عجيب غريب ويمكن ما يرحبوا فيها هيدا
الواقع نحن بلبنان منهرب من الواقع او
منصير نعمل شعارات ومزيده بكل بساطه
قادرين نخلي لبنان بمساحات متنوعه في
مناطق بيقدروا يروحوا بالمايوه ويمكن ما
بعرف شو بيعملوا في مناطق محافظه الخلاصه
براي بهجه اخوه لبهيج اما ان يكون لبنان
مفتوحا لجميع ابنائه دون تمييز واما ان
يكون بلد خصوصيات دينيه لجميع الطوائف
وبدون استثناء مع العلم والفهم والتاكيد
ان الخصوصيه الطوائفيه تلغي علمانيه
الدوله من اساسها وقد بينت كل الانتخابات
السابقه ان اغلبيه اللبنانيين يصوتون
لاحزاب خصوصيات
[موسيقى]
الطوائفين
طائفي
اخيرا نجمه الافلام الاباحيه المعتزله ميا
خليفه تكرم في جامعه اوكسفورد البريطانيه
الشهيره حيث حاضرت في الطلاب الذين
استقبلوها بوابل من التصفيق والهتفات ذلك
انها وجه او جسد معروف
واجلست ميا على كرسيا جلست عليه قبلها
الام ترازا لكن العالم تبدل وتبدل كثيرا
بكل الاحوال ميه مرتاحه لا احد يتهمها
بالارهاب ولا بالتزمد بل تفتح لها صالونات
الشرف الشرف المعاصر خلاصه الكلام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختاما يقول تسعيني عربي لو كانت اسرائيل
تملك قاده شجعانا مثل بعض الطراز العربي
المعاصر لتحررت فلسطين منذ زمن بعيد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
فيدائي
فدائي
فدائي يا ارضي يا ارض الجذور
فدائي شعبيه شعب الخلود بعجمي وناري
وبركان ثري
واشواق دمي لاراضي
صعدت الجبالا
قهرت المحاله عطلت القيود
فدائي
فدائي يا ارضي يا ارض الجدود
فدائي يا شعبي يا شعب
[موسيقى]